Another important class of image processing
operations are what we call diadic operations.
Now diadic operations have got two input arguments
and one output. As we discussed for the monadic
case, we have an arbitrary function; in this
case it is a function of two input variables
which we will call x and y. So it is f(x,y).
And that function is applied to the corresponding
pixels from the two input images, and the
result is deposited in the corresponding element
of the output image. All three images have
to be exactly the same size and we apply the
same function to every pixel in the two input
images.
So what sort of functions are useful for diadic
image processing? What is this function f
of x and y?
Well we could perform arithmetic, we could
add two images together or we could subtract
two images, or we could multiply two images.
We could also perform more complex functions
like perhaps take the square root of the sum
of the squares.
When it comes to implementing some of these
diadic operations, MATLAB’s inbuilt vectorization
capacity comes to our aid.
So if I was to add two matrices together,
and I do that by using the plus operator,
what MATLAB will do is add the corresponding
elements of each matrix, deposit the result
into the corresponding element of the output
matrix.
Once again all of these matrices are of exactly
the same size.
So we can use any of MATLAB’s arithmetic
operators and we can also use any of MATLAB’s
built-in logical operators.
If we use the logical operators what happens
is that the corresponding elements of the
input matrices are compared using that logic
operator and the result, either true or false,
is deposited into the corresponding element
in the output matrix.
Now you might notice here that amongst the
arithmetic operators there are a couple of
unusual ones.
One is .* and that means multiply the corresponding
elements of the input matrices together.
And the other one is ./ which means divide
the corresponding elements of the input matrices.
In MATLAB if you use just the * operator,
that is a traditional matrix multiplication
which is quite different. Here we are talking
about multiplying element by element.
Similarly, ./ means element wise division
of corresponding elements in the input matrices,
where / refers to multiplication by an inverse
of a matrix, quite a different thing.
Let’s have a look at a possible example
of a diadic operator and in this particular
case we will look at image subtraction—one
image minus another image.
So here is an image of an intersection taken
from a high vantage point and looking down.
And here is another frame from this same sequence—it
is actually the fourth frame in the sequence.
And these images look very, very similar to
each other. The traffic is not moving very
quickly at all.
But if I subtract these two images, I get
an image that looks like this. And what it
has done is it has shown us whereabouts the
two images are different. It shows us the
discrepancy between the two images. And what
we can see is that there are some bright pixels
up here. So this shows quite clearly whereabouts
the two images are different and we can see
that the difference is mostly in that column
of traffic, which is beginning to move downward
in the frame.
Although the images look very, very similar,
simply by taking the difference it really
highlights where the change in the image has
occurred.
But we do need to be a little bit careful
when we subtract pixel values, particularly
if they are of the unsigned integer eight
type that we have used previously.
Consider this example. Consider a pixel in
frame one has got a value of 55. The corresponding
pixel in frame two has got a value of 55.
The difference: clearly 0.
Now in this particular case the pixel in frame
one has got a value of 60, it is a bit bigger
then the value of the pixel in frame two.
The difference is clearly of 5.
Now in this case when the frame one pixel
has got a value of 55, the frame two pixel
has got a value of 60, MATLAB will compute
a difference of zero and this is because we
are subtracting unsigned integers. Unsigned
integers cannot be negative by definition,
they are unsigned. So in this case we are
going to get an erroneous result.
The way to get around it is to cast the images
to a different data type; move them from being
unsigned integers, perhaps to being signed integers, or perhaps to being double precision floating point values.
Let’s create a tangible example of this.
I am going to create a camera, a movie camera,
which is a special type of object which opens
a movie file and returns the frames of that
as individual grey scale images.
So I have created the movie object; it is
in the workspace called cam. It is a movie
object. And now I am going to grab one frame
from that movie.
So I am going to use the grab method, which
we have seen before and I am going to grab
the first frame out of the movie. And I am
going to grab the next frame out of the movie,
so two sequential frames. Now I am going to
display the image difference and I am going
to display the image which is the result of
image one minus image two.
And here we see a grey scale image and it
looks a little bit unusual and we can see
some interesting activity around here.
The result of im1 minus im2 is actually a
signed quantity. The pixel in image one could
be smaller then the pixel in image two. So
it is useful to display this with a different
colour map and I am going to use the option
invsigned here. And what it is going to do
is display pixels that are negative as red
and pixels that are positive as blue, and
the background, where it is 0, is white.
So let’s zoom in on this part of the image
up here. And what we can see is some red pixels
and some blue pixels and this is showing us
where the pixels in the image have changed
from one frame to the next.
So this is where there is motion in the scene.
If we go back and look at the original movie
we can see that this is where the traffic
starts to move across the intersection. These
are the only pixels in the scene that are
changing. We can use this image difference
mechanism to determine which parts of the
scene have been changed.
Let’s discuss a more sophisticated image
processing operation. It is what is called
the green screen effect. And what we want
to do is to superimpose this abstract scene
of a hat, a ball and a ladder into the scene
of a road in a desert.
What we want to do is to merge these two images,
and we are going to do that using the information
in the top image, where those pixels that
are green are going to be substituted by the
background pixels from the bottom image.
The green screen effect is widely used in
television production and here is an image
of me filming one of the introductory pieces
for the MOOC. All of the pixels that are in
the green background are substituted by a
number of photographs and graphics and so
on.
This effect is also used by newsreaders, weather
men on TV. When I am doing this it is really
important that I don’t wear anything that
is green. If, for instance, I wore a green
shirt then my body would just disappear, and
it would be replaced by the background photographs.
So let’s talk about how we do the green
screen effect. So here are the two images
again. In the top we have our abstract image
against the green background and in the bottom
we have the real scene that we want to superimpose
the abstract image into.
The first step is to determine which pixels
are green and we do that by making two decisions
and we create two logical images. The top
one shows all the pixels that are not green.
So white value means that the corresponding
input pixel is not green. The bottom one is
the opposite of that: the white pixels correspond
to green in the input image. These images
are logical images. The pixels have only got
the value true or false. Sometimes these are
called binary images because they only have
two possible values. Sometimes they are called
mask images because we use them to mask out
particular regions of the input scene.
The next step then is to multiply the mask
matrices by the original input images. And
what we have in the top line is an image where
all of the green pixels have been set to black,
and the remaining pixels are the abstract
object.
We do the same thing for the bottom image.
We multiply the input image by the mask and
now we have the input image with a hole in
it. The black pixels correspond to the abstract
object.
Notice that we have used the diadic operation
twice here, in each case to multiply a masked
matrix by an original colour image.
The last step then is to add these two images
together. And that is yet another diadic operation,
and what we are left with then is an image
which contains our abstract object against
the background of a desert scene.